au milieu d'un parc industriel de
boisbriand l'institut de l'oeil des
laurentides
cet édifice a coûté 10 millions de
dollars il est né d'un partenariat entre
des ophtalmologistes et le gouvernement
la médecine business tout cela pour
garantir les chirurgies de la cataracte
pendant la rénovation de l'hôpital de
saint-girons une aventure qui a coûté
cher à la fois au gouvernement et aux
patients sauf pour ce vraiment baiser
fait un peu permettez-moi terme plus
calmes pendant que les sites hugues
l'oeil des laurentides dû piger dans la
poche de ses patients il se servait
allègrement dans les fonds publics
grâce à une entente lucrative en quatre
ans les médecins actionnaires sont
devenus des millionnaires de la qatar à
[Musique]
roger et c'est celle wallet ont passé le
cap des 80
le cop le wallet est un bon exemple des
effets de la médecine à deux vitesses au
québec madame wallet a eu une chirurgie
de la cataracte pour les deux yeux à
l'hôpital elle est opéré gratuitement et
a dû payer 600 $ pensée de lentilles
source
son mari a eu la même opération à
l'institut le des laurentides
il a déboursé près de 1500 dollars près
de trois fois plus cher
une situation inadmissible pour jean
louis le fils du couple où elle est
ça donne un écart de plus de 1100 $ pour
la même intervention
ça commence à faire beaucoup en frais
accessoires ce contenu que c'est une
chirurgie qui devraient être couverts
par la régie de l'assurance maladie
alors est-ce que c'est acceptable je
vous dirais que non la différence entre
les coûts s'explique par les frais
accessoires facturés aux patients par
l'institut
au total pour les opérations deux yeux
et pour tous les examens c'est 1955
dollars 2 gouttes diverses qui sont
facturés pourtant le prix coûtant de ces
médicaments n'est que de quelques cents
à cela s'ajoute un examen de la forme de
l'oeil une biométrie pour 125 dollars
c'est pas normal que des professionnels
de la santé puissent abuser du système
et puis surtout abuser des personnes
âgées en particulier sont souvent des
personnes qui sont démunis qui sont pas
dans une position pour se défendre
correctement sauf pour ce vraiment abusé
fait un peu permettez-moi de terremer
plus qu'un bel si ce n'était que des
frais accessoires
mais l'institut de l'oeil des
laurentides a eu pendant quatre ans une
autre source de revenus bien plus
importante
5 ophtalmologiste de la région des
laurentides unissent leurs forces et
créer un projet unique au canada
ce training privé a vu le jour en 2010
l'institut est une clinique hors norme
25 salles d'examen et cinq salles
d'opération à la fine pointe de la
technologie
c'est la réponse des ophtalmologistes de
l'hôpital de saint jérôme à la décision
de rénover leur département les docteurs
martin boileau laurent lalonde
robert lepage et suzanne racines sont
les membres fondateurs de l'institut des
les laurentides
ces spécialistes c'est ensuite une
entente temporaire avec le centre de
santé et de services sociaux de
saint-girons plus but prendre en charge
la clientèle de l'hôpital durant les
rénovations qui devait durer deux ans
cette entente de services a été plus que
lucrative pour ses médecins elle leur
garantissait un financement pour couvrir
les coûts d'exploitation de la clinique
du personnel à l'équipement au final le
gouvernement leur a versé la somme de 34
millions deux cent quarante huit mille
dollars
françois therrien était le patron à
l'époque si lui qui a signé la première
entente à titre de directeur général du
c3s de saint-girons
il est maintenant à la retraite pour lui
cette entente était un exemple classique
de partenariat public privé et les
médecins voulaient un contrat qui leur
rapporterait gros plein en tant qu'ils
faisaient que les lyonnais auraient pu
m'adapter
après des mois de négociations enquête a
obtenu d'une source des rapports annuels
de l'entreprise
ce que nous avons découvert est étonnant
juste pour l'année 2011
l'institut a fait un profit net après
impôts de 4 millions huit cent soixante
six mille dollars
mais pour un édifice qui vous dit lyon à
ses fonctions pendant 4 à l'édifice est
payé tout à fait donc c'est la passer
pour le revenu se c'est juste le revenu
lidl de bruit c'est les autres
effectivement c'est tentant de 34
millions n'inclut pas la rémunération un
ophtalmologiste au québec facture en
moyenne à la ramq eu six cent quarante
cinq mille dollars annuellement selon
nos sources certains à l'institut de
l'oeil les laurentides avait une
rémunération frôlant les deux millions $
en fait pour chaque chirurgie de la
cataracte
les médecins pouvaient tirer au montant
d'environ 1300 75 dollars 2,3 source de
l'entente des frais accessoires et de
leur rémunération d'aram q cette
opération duré plus d'une heure trente
il ya quelques années maintenant elle ne
dure que de 10 à 15 minutes ce qui leur
permet d'en faire 40 par jour ce qui
leur a permis au cours de l'année
financière 2011 de facturer la somme
astronomique de trois millions et demi
en frais accessoires à leurs patients
dont plus de 300 mille dollars en
gouttes ophtalmiques
une d'entre elles alcaïne était facturé
25 dollars mais le goûter que 300 la
goutte
même livré que ce soit par paresse aussi
chargé c'était selon les recommandations
de la fédération des médecins
spécialistes
maintenant quand prince est son pâle au
plus beau de la claie recommandations
mais sont pas les plus hauts que les
standards et il n'y a pas que l'argent
nous avons obtenu des témoignages
troublants de la part des employés de
l'institut selon eux certains goûtent
donner au patient n'était pas
médicalement requises et étaient bien
souvent des larmes artificielles fourni
gratuitement à l'institut c'était des
larmes artificielles que les conditions
nous donner comme était aux patients
vous voulez me dire que ce avait aucun
besoin médical et que c'était juste de
l'eau finalement oui un comportement
inadmissible pour la présidente de
médecins québécois pour le régime public
ça peut montrer comment une institution
qui est là pour prendre soin des
patients mais pour prendre soin de leurs
profits un peu faire des choses qui sont
aberrantes
toujours selon les ex employés
il y a même un examen particulier une
pio mitri par ultrasons pour mesurer la
taille du globe oculaire qui était
facturé inutilement ont fait la
biométrie par ultrasons quand c'est un
cristallin qui est plus blanc qui
prudence mais ça c'est à peu près 10% de
la population qui en a besoin mais on
rentrer les données dans l'appareil pour
tout le monde même ceux qui en avaient
pas besoin
parce que là ça permettait à
l'ophtalmologie est de facturer cette
cette biométrie là et là il le faisait
pas assez à tout le monde on rentrait
les données dans l'appareil
parce que ce qu'ils disaient c'est que
s'ils avaient un audit fait par la ramq
qu ils pouvaient prouver que tout le
monde a des noeuds dans le fond 90% des
gens ne l'ont pas exactement si on en
fait 100 % par ultrasons leur prête
juste 10% il ya un gros gros problème
dans la qualité des soins ce quelque
chose au collège de médecins devrait
soit quelque régime entre ce projet il
en va de même pour une autre procédure
le marquage de l'oeil qui est fait avant
l'implantation de lentilles
intraoculaires pour les astigmate les
lentilles tories selon le personnel ont
procédé au marquage pour d'autres types
de lentilles inutilement alors pourquoi
est ce qu'il le faisait mais parce qu'il
le réclamait après ça dans le reçues il
y avait un frêle de 300 $ pour un
marquage qui était pas nécessaire
pour le personnel la cadence de travail
étaient à la limite du soutenable
avec plus de 40 chirurgie de la
cataracte deux par jour ça allait
tellement vite que si on voulait arriver
bien des fois fait les superviser deux
champs visuel en même temps ça fait qd
tu dis c'est sur l'eau qui peut y avoir
un risque d'erreur la supervision et
possibilités on s'entend c'était
vraiment sous pression
vraiment vraiment parce qu'on se met en
moyenne là écoutez c'était 500 patients
par jour
même en tout cas j'aime autant mourir
demain matin puis pas me faire soigner
par ce genre de médecins l'eau
non il n'est pas question ces poissons
qu'on veut moi quand je vais bien je
veux pas me faire traiter comme ça
[Musique]
l'institut de l'oeil des laurentides
obtenu une entente public privé des plus
lucratives les médecins de l'institut
ont refusé de nous accorder une entrevue
devant la caméra pour discuter des
détails entourant ce partenariat
même son de cloche du côté des actuels
dirigeants du centre intégré de santé et
de services sociaux des laurentides
ils ont aussi refusé de commenter ces
ententes devant la caméra
pourtant l'histoire mérite des
explications
selon l'entente les médecins de
l'institut devait offrir une portion de
leurs services gratuitement comme à
l'hôpital
mais ce qu'il proposait était nettement
insuffisant
deux jours par mois de biométrie
gratuite et huit jours de goat le
commissaire aux plaintes de l'hôpital a
donc reçu de nombreuses plaintes à
l'effet que cette offre était
insuffisante et est praticable pour les
patients
le protecteur du citoyen fait enquête et
conclu
[Musique]
les journées de gratuité établi ne
favorise pas une gratuité des services
en tout temps pour les usagers
à la fin de l'entente de deux ans les
ophtalmologistes sont insatisfaits des
rénovations du département
d'ophtalmologie de l'hôpital de
saint-girons ils ne veulent pas
retourner travailler à l'hôpital y exige
alors outre contrat s'ensuivent des
négociations difficiles qui dure
plusieurs mois
occasionnant une rupture de service
gratuit de deux jours par mois
au total plus de 2000 services médicaux
ont dû être remboursés aux patients par
le c3s spectacle ce que je vois à l'ock
et on prend pas place à noter une
deuxième entente est finalement signé
pour deux autres années
elle se terminera le 30 juin 2014
dans les mois qui ont suivi le c3s s'est
plaint publiquement que les médecins de
l'institut retenaient leurs patients
pour qu'ils ne retournent pas à
l'hôpital au final le protecteur du
citoyen met en relief que ce partenariat
public-privé dessert mal la population
il est préoccupant que des
ophtalmologistes de l'iol ayant des
privilèges de pratique au c3s est
également des intérêts économiques à
titre d'administrateur et ou
d'actionnaires de l'iol l'existence d'un
conflit d'intérêts possibles entre les
besoins cliniques des usagers et la
recherche des intérêts financiers de lio
elle doit être envisagée
même le service midi qualité douteuse au
cours de la seconde entente
le personnel s'est fait demander de
participer aux actes médicaux dont les
réceptionnistes il n'était pas formé
pour cela était monsieur et madame tout
un secondaire 5 qui travaillent n'ont pu
tenir un bureau et qui reçoit avec
accueille les patients points
on leur demandait de faire des tests
d'acuité visuelle ou des thèses pression
de la wii même chose pour les préposés
aux bénéficiaires à qui l'on demandé de
badigeonner le champ père at war et bien
d'autres premièrement c'était de prendre
les pressions de prendre les tests de
diabète le but comète sur le bout du
doigt ont gelé l'oeil des patients la
première goutte c'est agen nous autres
qui met à la première goutte c'était
toujours l'infirmière de la salle qui
mettait les premières gouttes
après ça nous ôtons continuer les
gouttes ou 15 minutes est inadmissible
et des professionnels de la santé qui
sont formés pour poser ces gestes là on
peut pas former une secrétaire
réceptionniste au préposé pour faire des
choses qui sont du ressort d'un
infirmier auxiliaire d'une infirmière ou
d'un médecin donc il ya vraiment un gros
problème là
l'institut selon les ex employés
interrogés arrivait à une grande
productivité parce que tous les employés
étaient mises à contribution pour
accélérer le service médical de la
médecine business faire attention c'est
aussi parce que c'est son talent ce look
se développe aussi le problème c'est que
ministère est au courant tout ça mais
l'éducation c'est la taille dans
l'ensemble c'est là la fatalité
l'incapacité de faire face est chose a
dit ça roule pas en remettre
il n'y a pas un cadre aux mets de
l'argent l'institut de l'oeil des
laurentides a pris beaucoup de place
le système public des laurentides en a
souffert durant la période des ententes
et même après à l'hôpital de
saint-eustache par exemple on n'a jamais
réussi à démarrer au département
d'ophtalmologie comme nous l'expliquent
cet ophtalmologiste des laurentides
les médecins de l'institut ont fait de
l'ingérence saint-eustache
officiellement trois hôtels mot logist
il y en a un qui est actionnaire à
l'institut deuil
il y en a un autre qui travaille à
l'institut de l'oeil donc c'est un
travail de ces ophtalmologiste l'autre
bâtiment département à l'hôpital de
saint-eustache
c'est certain quand on regarde les
candidats les acteurs dans ce scénario
il y en a 2 dont on peut se poser la
question est ce qu'ils ont vraiment
intérêt à voir un département sein de
l'hôpital à saint-eustache
[Musique]
pour déstabiliser le service public
encore plus certains des patients
traités à l'institut qui en ressortent
avec des complications doivent se
rabattre dans les urgences des hôpitaux
en dehors des heures d'affaires devrait
avoir à tout le moins un échange de bons
procédés puis devrait avoir quelqu'un
qui est de garde pour faire ça pour
assurer les meilleurs soins pour les
patients mais en ce moment ce que je
comprends ce que ces pâles copies sont
juste envoyé vers l'urgence la plus
proche c'est un problème je pense que
faudra peut-être voir avec le collège
des médecins
ce genre d'entente que l'on nomme une
entente 108 risque de revenir à chaque
fois qu'on rénove l'hôpital au québec
va-t-on tirer des leçons il ya des
petits groupes de médecins qui prennent
facilement la population la tâche pour
chaque fois il faut que ça vous narrer
ce faucon repenser complètement de
quelle manière on organise la pratique
médicale on les pays qui se veut besoin
de moins bien payés médecin gérard mary
soit bien payé
il faut que la population est la
contrepartie commun qu'on peut mieux
définir les rôles et responsabilités des
balises claires et directes
ça tombe bien on est dans un contexte on
aime beaucoup les directives bien
comment ça devrait être favorisée nans
dans ce champ de développement convoi
qui va se faire pour qu'on va revenir en
arrière au québec qui se fait plus de
cent mille opérations de la cataracte
par année il d'ici dix ans on prévoit
que ce nombre augmentera de plus de 40%
les personnes âgées sont de plus en plus
confrontées cette chirurgie dans un
système public pourront nous garantir
l'accessibilité et la gratuité de ce
soin
la famille ou à l'aide s'est jointe à un
recours collectif contre les frais
accessoires pour tout au moins tenter
d'obtenir gain de cause
je réagis ici pour simplement pour mon
père mais aussi pour toutes les années
qui ont subi le même préjudice
depuis la fin des ententes en 2014 le
service public offre de l'ophtalmologie
aux hôpitaux de saint-girons et de
sainte agathe
malgré cela l'institut le des
laurentides embaucher des lobbyistes
pour obtenir une troisième entente une
nouvelle ébauche est maintenant prête
mais n'a pas encore été signé elle
serait d'une durée de cinq ans va-t-elle
être aussi généreuse pour les médecins
qu'aux les deux premières passes comme
un pipeline qui coule dans une seule
direction sans contrôle du tout du tout
l'argent vote du public au privé sans
trop savoir comment peuvent ils
utilisent sans imputabilité
il
[Musique]